bienvenidos de nuevo en el vídeo pasado
yo había encontrado en la casa de mis
sueños y valía un millón de pesos sin
embargo yo no tenía esta cantidad de
dinero por lo tanto iba al banco y le
pedía prestado 750 mil pesos y el banco
me decía oye sal pues si te los voy a
prestar porque tienes un buen este
historial crediticio y además eres una
persona que siempre paga sus deudas y
eres una buena persona en general es un
tipazo por lo tanto si te voy a prestar
el dinero ya con estos 750 mil pesos en
efectivo que me prestó el banco más los
250 mil pesos en efectivo que yo tenía
por haber trabajado y ahorrado durante
toda mi vida me voy a comprar mi casa de
un millón de pesos y entonces esta es mi
hoja de balance personal cuando ya me
compré la casa lo primero que quiero que
vean es que yo tengo de activo un millón
de pesos porque ya me compré mi casa en
mi casa ha valido al millón de pesos de
hecho mi casa es mi único activo y bueno
eso es porque el carisma y la buena onda
no se pueden cuantificar por lo tanto no
pueden ser activos así que mi único
activo es mi casa de un millón de pesos
y cuáles son mis deudas cuál es mi
pasivo mi pasivo son 750 mil pesos que
le debo al banco
para sacar mi capital recuerde la
fórmula activo es igual a pasivo más
capital o dicho de otra manera si
despejamos de que el capital activo
menos pasivo es igual al capital por lo
tanto si yo tengo un millón de pesos en
mi activo y tengo 750 mil pesos en el
pasivo pues yo tengo un capital de 250
mil pesos y bueno yo sigo insistiendo
que esta fórmula nos ayuda bastante a
tener un mejor sentido de lo que
significa la palabra capital hoy lo
podemos ver de la siguiente manera si
nosotros agarramos todo lo que tenemos y
le quitamos todo lo que debemos a las
demás personas eso es a lo que se
refiere el capital así que vamos a jugar
con los distintos escenarios que pueden
suceder a partir de aquí y bueno antes
de seguir con este vídeo me gustaría
aclararles que la gente de los bancos no
son nada tontos es decir si me van a
prestar 750 mil pesos no me van a decir
tener los 750 mil pesos aquí los tienes
hay menos pagas cuando quieras ellos sé
que eres una persona que paga muy bien
por lo tanto hay menos pagas cuando
quieras todos puedes ir a gastar oa
jugar o apostar y luego menos regresas
no toquéis maná decides bueno te voy a
prestar los 750 mil pesos y uno te voy a
cobrar intereses
además de correr te interesa y yo
necesito una garantía de que menos vas a
pagar por lo tanto lo que me van a decir
es lo siguiente sal te voy a prestar
estos 750 mil pesos pero tú tienes de
dos opciones o me regresas estos 750 mil
pesos que yo te acabo de prestar o me
voy a tener que cobrar esta deuda con
alguno de tus activos entonces yo les
voy a decir bueno yo quiero hasta 750
mil pesos para comprar una casa de un
millón de pesos que me encantó y me la
quiero comprar entonces blanco como es
mi único activo si yo no te puedo pagar
estos 750 mil pesos o me desaparezco un
día o no se me pasa algo entonces tú vas
a poder quedarte con la casa y de hecho
parece ser un buen trato porque la casa
vale un millón de pesos por lo tanto el
banco va a esperar a que yo no españa es
más veamos este caso hipotético que yo
en el primer día no logró pagar en el
primer día me corren de mi trabajo y
entonces yo puedo con el banco y les
digo banco no tengo forma de pagarte
estos 750 mil pesos
que me prestas te por lo tanto ellos se
van a cobrar con mi casa y en un día
solamente en un día ellos consiguieron
doscientos cincuenta mil pesos más de
los 750 mil pesos que me prestaron y es
aquí donde las cosas para los bancos
funcionan bastante bien porque si
ocurriera esta situación en una noche se
quedarían con mi casa de un millón de
pesos y por lo tanto con todo mi capital
y todos mis ahorros de toda mi vida que
eran 250 mil pesos y en este caso es
donde se recurre a la hipoteca porque
seamos realistas la gente del banco no
se va a sentar afuera de la casa a
esperar que alguien llegue y compre la
casa podrían pasar meses sentados
esperando a que alguien llegue y compren
la casa por lo tanto van a utilizar la
hipoteca ahora sí de plano lo puedes
pagar la hipoteca a lo que se le ocurre
es a subastar la casa en lugar de
esperar meses y meses a vender tu casa
lo que van a hacer es subastar tu casa y
ya qué se refiere eso bueno que es la
casa tal vez no den a un millón de pesos
tal vez la den en 800 mil pesos para que
se vendan de una manera mucho más rápida
y así el banco se quite del problema en
el que está y por qué venderla en 800
mil pesos le bajaron
un 25 por ciento del valor de la casa
porque bajarle tanto al valor de la casa
lo que pasa es lo siguiente el banco va
a recuperar el préstamo que te dio de
750 mil pesos le va a ganar un poco tal
vez le gane 50 mil pesos en este caso
pero el devaluado de la casa que casi
siempre es del 20 al 25 por ciento el de
valor de la casa sales de tu capital es
decir de los ahorros de toda tu vida que
se fueron cuando el banco se quedó con
tu casa espero que hasta aquí me haya
dado a entender si no para mejorar esto
voy a hacer una hoja de balance otra vez
ahora en esta situación en la situación
en la cual el banco me diga que tengo
que liquidar mi deuda y yo por lo tanto
voy a tener que darle la casa el banco
va a tener que subastar en mi casa y
bueno como estos demasiado doloroso para
mí mejor vamos a suponer que es la casa
de mi vecino que mi vecino tiene una
casa idéntica a la mía solamente que él
va a tener que subastar su casa y
entonces van a dar su casa en 800 mil
pesos para esto lo que sucede es lo
siguiente yo voy a hacer honesto más aún
las compañías tratan de ser honestas
así funciona y entonces lo que hacen es
lo siguiente dicen el valor de esta casa
es de un millón de pesos seamos
realistas sin embargo yo no puedo
venderla en un millón de pesos por lo
tanto lo que voy a hacer es un ajuste de
mercado es decir voy a venderla en 800
mil pesos vamos a hacer una hoja de
balance para que quede mucho más claro
lo que va a suceder voy a vender esta
casa ahora me activo va a ser de 800 mil
pesos
realmente me activo era de un millón de
pesos y esto es justo lo que se hace en
un ajuste al mercado para entender mejor
este término vamos a ver lo siguiente yo
tengo un cierto activo no sé supongamos
que es esta casa entonces para ello
saber el valor de esta casa después de
un cierto tiempo no sé muchas veces
utiliza después de un año después de un
mes hay veces que hasta cuatro meses en
un año es decir muy en un cuarto de año
y para ello saber el valor de este
activo lo que tengo que hacer es
compararlo con un activo idéntico en
este caso estamos suponiendo que tanto
mi casa como la casa de mi vecino son
casas idénticas y como mi vecino no tuvo
para pagar su casa y entonces remataron
su casa
800 mil pesos mi casa por lo tanto ya
vale 800 mil pesos es decir bajó de
precio se devaluó entonces ahora tengo
unos activos de 800 mil pesos
sigo debiendo de albany con 750 mil
pesos por el préstamo que me dieron de
mi casa entonces vamos a escribirlo aquí
tengo mis pasivos que son 750 mil pesos
que le debo al banco y por lo tanto
tengo un capital de 50 mil pesos mi
capital bajó bastante en esta ocasión lo
que pasó es que como en la casa de mi
vecino se devaluó no sé supongamos que
mi vecino no puedo pagar la casa o que
mi vecino tuvo que rematar la casa
porque la delincuencia ha subido
bastante en esta zona o se cerró una
gran compañía o una grande empresa en
esta misma ciudad por lo tanto él tuvo
que rematar a su casa y por lo tanto
como en mi casa era idéntica a la suya
también mi casa ha bajado de precio y se
ha devaluado por lo tanto mi capital ha
bajado de 250 mil pesos a 50 mil pesos y
más aún si yo no pudiera pagar esta casa
otra vez porque me quedé sin trabajo
o me tengo que ir de del país no lo sé
no puedo pagar esta casa y el banco se
queda con mi casa entonces esta casa no
la puede vender en un millón de pesos la
va a vender solamente en 800 mil pesos
ellos van a recuperar el préstamo que me
hicieron y dense en cuenta que en esta
ocasión el ajuste al mercado que se hizo
porque mi vecino vendió su casa no le
conviene a nadie pero este vídeo no
acaba aquí también podemos ver un tercer
escenario y este tercer escenario es
mucho más positivo que el que acabamos
de ver es lo que está sucediendo en
algunas partes de eeuu como el
california o florida elevada en los
últimos cinco años el cual es el
escenario contrario imagínense que ahora
su vecino vende su casa en un millón y
medio de pesos ahora van a vender la
casa en un millón quinientos mil pesos
por lo tanto como tu casa y la casa de
tu vecino son idénticas entonces tu casa
ahora tiene el mismo valor es decir tu
activo va a ser de un millón y medio de
pesos 1.5 millones de pesos este es tu
activo por tu casa entonces
escribirlo y darte cuenta que tu casa
aumento de valor gracias a que tu vecino
supo vender muy bien su casa espero
hacer próximamente un vídeo que explique
con mucha más calma por qué pasa este
tipo de situaciones y bueno recuerda que
tú le debe al banco 750 mil pesos por lo
tanto este es tu pasivo y aquí aquí es
donde ya cambio todo porque cuánto va a
ser tu capital capital recuerda que es
lo mismo que activo menos pasivo por lo
tanto ahora tiene 750 mil pesos de
capital tu capital aumentó 3 veces es
decir aumentó en un 200 por ciento en
esta ocasión el ajuste al mercado te
cayó de maravilla y esto es lo que se
conoce como el efecto palanca el efecto
palanca ocurre cuando tú usas una deuda
para comprar un activo y ese activo
aumenta su valor y por lo tanto afecta a
tu capital aumentando lo esperando
confundirte y como ahora estoy viendo
los logs y empiezo a correr un poco en
el tiempo mejor te voy a contar que en
el siguiente vídeo lo que voy a analizar
es por qué pasa este efecto palanca es
decir me voy a fijar en las casas del
2001 al 2005 en las cuales se empezaron
a vender con un precio mucho más elevado
por lo tanto la gente sin hacer nada al
estar solamente sentadas en su casa
terminaron teniendo un buen de capital
por ejemplo en este caso aumentaron su
riqueza de 250 mil pesos a 750 mil pesos
sin hacer nada solamente porque el
vecino vendió su casa a un precio más
alto